it's my favorite gay wasyou I guess but
that we have to be careful with you have
a terminology you could follow them on
the Twitter at Rubin report and you can
follow him on YouTube youtube.com slash
Rubin report for as long as he's allowed
to still be there dave rubin how are you
sir
well first off Crowder a lot of people
right now a lot of people telling me
that you're a homophobe yes that that's
word out on the street now of course a
phobe is a phobia phobia is an
irrational fear so I thought though
you're interviewing me here I would ask
you the first question do you have an
irrational fear of gay people like if a
gay person is saying walking down the
street and you're walking this way do
you freak out like you know like is this
yourself is this gonna lead you telling
everybody that I hugged you again and
you try to embarrass me and ruin my
street cred one time once in person and
you get very very warm uncomfortably
long hug okay well that always feels
great coming from a man who typically
likes hugs for men but so heaps by the
way helps rational fear because people
are gonna be angry just that I'm even
talking to you right now you deny my
existence Crowder you're you're coming
for gay people even though you're
dressed like a member of the Village
People what the hell is going on here
this is a irrational fear isn't
mallanna's Morissette were added as a
member you know I don't necessarily
think so but um you know I don't like
the parties they get a little bit loud I
lived in Chelsea for a year and there
was a little bit tough to find sleep I'm
not gonna lie I was irritated that's
what it is so you look like that one
time was really like the gayest place in
New York I'm not sure if it still is
anymore I think maybe that sells kitchen
or out here we have West Hollywood and I
think a lot of what happens with you in
the gays is you do have a little PTSD
from living in Chelsea where there's a
lot of parties it's very loud there's
people screaming and having good time
they have something called Sunday Funday
I've never had that fun on a Sunday we
just call it a Sabbath they're like he
had half that like funding from about
8:00 a.m. to about 10:00 p.m. that's
pretty much it for me yeah by the way
how yeah so how offended were you at the
apology because under like man Reuben is
pissed that you'd made the rock
and Gomer Pyle bit okay oh I didn't
think the joke itself was that great I
would have appreciated an open girls
reference you know Blanche's brother
Clayton was a very straight acting gay
guy I would have preferred that that
would have worked a little more comedic
Lee for me yes but what you're doing the
right thing here man you cannot bow to
these people and you know it's not a
coincidence that the same guy that's
going after you I don't even need to
mention his name but if you want it you
can the same box guy that's going out
the gentleman and scholar from vox of
Latino origin who happens to be
attracted to members of the same sex
which is both beautiful and brave yes
continue yes it is I don't care what his
gender is I don't care about any of
those in beautiful characters what I
care is about what someone does with
their life and in this case this is the
same guy the same guy now going after
you and trying to take down your channel
and making a whole hullabaloo about it
this is the same guy that a couple weeks
ago I think you know this I was trying
to get people to judge on the show
tweeted at tweeted at Buddha judge his
immediately his PR press people say DME
I get it you know the head of PR for him
he says DME start going back and forth
we trade some emails he's got a trip
coming to the gym in coming to LA in
June we're gonna work it out and then
next thing you know this guy and a
Huffington Post journalist and Media
Matters the CEO president of Media
Matters
all jump in to start the mob attacking
the press guy of mayor P so that he
won't do my show and then they just stop
responding what was the reasoning well
I'm a scary dude gonna say like here's
the one thing if anything the only valid
criticism I would say of you is that you
tend to be very nice with everybody like
you I don't think I've ever seen you get
in somebody's grill I would love to see
that is it a funny Crowder that we live
in a time where everybody's always upset
that everybody hates each other right
everyone's trying to destroy each other
we're more polarized than ever before I
mean these are all the just the things
people say right then I come around and
I really I've treated you included I
have treated every single one of my team
act as though I should have been the
exception to that rule but every single
one of my guests exactly the same
whether I've had Bishop Baron in here
from the archdiocese in my own
where I lived with my husband and he's
obviously not for gay marriage I treated
him with the exact amount of respect
that I've treated any of my lefty guests
that I would treat any libertarian or
any progressive with I treat everybody
exactly the same and that's partly why
I'm taking the hits right now because
they really it's one thing to go after
you because it's like you're saying I'm
a conservative I'm using comedy it to
really throw it in their face where me
like they don't know what to do with me
because if you looked if it was the back
of a baseball card they'd be like wait a
minute this guy is supposed to be a
lefty he acts nice you know he lives in
LA none of this adds up so that's why a
certain amount of hate is coming to me
but by the way you know this Fox
journalist and again I don't leave it I
can't i'm not even sure what his name
it's carlos i'm gentlemen's kala tato
origins same-sex attraction wonderful
beautiful brave yeah in his a twitter
bio it says that Tucker Carlson is a
white supremacist yeah yeah now that
seems pretty freakin directly hateful
directly potentially inciting violence
like to be a white supremacist but
especially when you see that he didn't
potentially incite he said milkshake as
he said assault commit battery against
white supremacists Rand has identified
people yeah left to the imagination
there's like we wouldn't call it
foreshadowing if this were an auteur
like oh he's a violent guy right so
think about what this guy's doing I mean
we have three examples now so yeah he's
trying to stop people from talking to me
as an interviewer no matter how moderate
I maybe he's trying to literally get you
booted off YouTube and he's putting
messaging out there as a journalist and
I've got air quotes calling that Tucker
Carlson is a white supremacist so this
is what this is why journalism is
collapsing this sucks on the YouTube
cron I mean they've been crushing my
channel even worse than yours
and it's like you know we just gotta we
gotta keep fighting man what else can we
do right I don't know if they've been
crushing you worse than ours you know do
you ever think that maybe the criticism
lobbed against you is it is that you are
very articulate you're very nice but
sometimes you you use expressions that
would sound like a 1940's homophobe like
see those two good time boys what the
hullabaloo these kids with their
hootenannies you I am 40 I'll be 43 in a
couple weeks
oh really you carry it well
that's that's the one thing with being
lighter you know being overall you're
smaller than I am have heavy heavy
weights don't age well there's a lot of
torque on the joints not aging well no
everyone knows that I'm not aging well
like even Dylan Ratigan picking you up
YouTube it's the fact that you're aging
horribly yes exactly like a pod loggers
Dark Crystal not quite as bad as Don
Lemon but he just didn't get the gene he
didn't get the the anti-aging day genes
I don't know what it is what time I'm
gonna you just see just the luck of the
draw so let me ask you this
just real quick real quick though
because look you I have no problem with
gay jokes I mean the idea that you can't
make fun of a certain group of people it
doesn't mean about destroying one
particular person over their identity
but imagine if you say okay well we
can't make gay jokes anywhere now first
off gay people are equal in America no
one's coming for you because you're gay
so if there were rights that gay
people's have no other gay guys but yeah
that's a joke see what you did there
tell me where that's hateful
yeah go ahead but the point is that you
make those jokes actually because you
know gay people are equal so the point
would be if gay people didn't have
certain rights and then you were
constantly going after gay people
personally I would have more of an issue
with that I would defend you as a
comedian and I would always defend your
right to free speech obviously the point
is if you're gonna come after jokes
let's just watch where this goes okay
guys box you want to take down Crowder
for gay jokes you got 20 years ago
joke's on Family Guy every frickin joke
about Stewie the baby is about him being
gay and and every gay character that
they've put in that show and the
Simpsons have done it with Waylon
Smithers and you could do every sick huh
every friends every other job would have
to get rid of RuPaul's Drag Race yeah
well now they don't like her her him
either because yeah and I be used the
word RuPaul against the word [ __ ] and
they were like I think not only I'm not
a bit about that see didn't clearly
didn't mean hatefully well let me ask
you this what's your biggest issue with
it when people would say this to you as
a you know you've you identify more
libertarian now what would you say to
people who say well Han something this
is this is about YouTube they have the
right to for example completely D
monetize whoever they want you shouldn't
be trying to influence market forces you
know or they can ban whoever they want
what's your response to that well the
libertarian answer would be that you do
try to influence market forces you don't
that the government get involved now I
think look this has pushed my
libertarian side to its limits because
the amount of power and control of
information and the way we communicate
and all of those things that YouTube and
Facebook and Twitter have over us I
think there could be an argument that
they should be considered a public good
the way you know water works and the
electric company for playing Monopoly
would be considered right right
so I there is an argument there I'm not
really for it and the idea that the
government should come in and regulate
YouTube and Google it's like I live in
California I pay my state taxes on the
California state website it looks like
prodigy in 1993 that might be too old of
a know I know exactly what time and then
we moved on to Angel Fire Angela fire
geo cities yes yeah so these people the
idea that the government could come in
and somehow that's gonna make it fair I
don't love if you so this is where a
libertarian to me it's like you want
competition now what I the pushback I
get on that from people on the right is
that this is this is a case where
competition can never flourish because
of the monopoly and amount of control
and of course the counter-argument to
that is that when you make that
exception once you will always make that
exception again and again and every time
government comes in they just make
things worse and all of those things so
so I I don't know that I'm fully decided
on this look a guy who I know we both
respect Dennis Prager Prager you sued
Google over restrict the videos it's not
really the mode that I would want to go
in I can tell you this I don't even know
that I fully said this publicly yet but
I started a tech company just in the
last couple months and we're working on
some of these solutions and you know
I've had unfortunate it's like you what
we have problems and people reach out to
us with solutions and we're gonna work
on some of those things can you work on
a solution of turning your phone off
vibrate you lay out you and Naomi Wolf
they are really not happy that I'm
talking to you I can't believe that you
know what tell them they're all welcome
to come on the show here's the deal they
can come on the show I'm not going to
change my opinions and I'm not going to
stop making jokes black jokes half asian
jokes quarter black jokes Canadian jokes
they're never going to stop I mean
people just need to understand this and
there's a big difference by the way that
we were just talking with David Barton
about this you know freedom of speech
people say well where do you draw the
line and they always use a stupid
example if you can't yell fire in a
crowded theater you can if there's a
fire the line is very simple you can
and lie you have a responsibility to
tell the truth so things like libel
slander those are actionable offenses
you cannot use your freedom of speech to
deliberately lie to harm somebody else
and outside of that that's it that
doesn't include nasty words or jokes
that offend it's deliberately lying to
cause harm physical or reputation wise
to someone else outside of that close
the books let me ask you would think of
the argument that they're gonna
basically leave people like us with no
choice other than to take legal action
against specific people so for example
you you will find no videos of me
slandering and and labelling people
right well either verbally or written
you won't find that but there are tons
of people that everyday call me a white
supremacist call me a Nazi I mean I grew
up around Holocaust survivors like try
to imagine the level of insanity of
those or the horrible things that they
say about you I I don't know that I've
ever seen you attack any specific person
with any of that kind of vitriol you're
do we need jokes
we need jokes you know what happens to a
society that can't joke violence I mean
that's what happens you start killing
each other jokes are a way of
illuminating a little bit of truth so
that we can all sort of feel the same
thing so the idea whoa all right we're
not gonna do you know Family Guy
actually is the right example because
about a year ago the producers said that
they weren't gonna do gay jokes anymore
I don't know if they've actually
followed through with that but it's like
once you say all right we're not gonna
do gay jokes well are you gonna do black
jokes cuz you've been doing that for 20
years you've been doing Jew jokes for 20
years am i doing must jokes for 20 years
and white people jokes once you start
pinning everybody off and we're not
gonna make fun of these people you're
you're actually mate you're saying that
group is the other and they deserve
special treatment and and that's not
good for them or for you or for a
functioning society in any way no I
think you're correct
let me ask it's just a ballpark how
effective is your channel been as a
percentage of your videos would you say
like demonetised compared to maybe let's
say four or five years ago it's been a
significant uptick well it's all over
the place so I I don't know specifically
I just tweeted out this morning that our
our Rebbe is off by about 66% since
March okay so there you go so 66% so
here's my issue is the dishonest
business practices right YouTube courted
someone like you they said we want you
here we're going to make you a part of
our part
program whatever you made you know they
made many many many fold more right they
made it off the backs of content
creators YouTube never created any
content so my issue is with them saying
hey dave rubin we know at this point
there could have been other options as
they were coming up and said we know
there other options we want to pay you
to create content for our website we
want YouTube to be your home and because
of you doing that for your loyalty we
are going to split the revenue with you
okay great and then when they grow big
enough they try to cut you off at the
knees to me that's dishonest business a
dishonest business practice it's not
about necessarily even corporate
censorship if they're clear about the
rules no one you know this thing
happened this week we're no one is still
entirely clear about whether we were
completely demonetised and booted if it
was due to a shirt and they couldn't
give us an answer no one understands the
rules and I think the simple intrusion
is following the law yeah I mean well
look that's why perhaps legal action is
going to be necessary and it would suck
for people like us to have to be
involved in that you would really as I
said it would push me to really the
limits of what my my belief in freedom
and liberty is all about but they may
leave us with no choice but yeah at the
end of the day look we don't have to be
on this platform but we do we do do
something where we want to get our
message out there and there's other ways
we could do it through podcasts and
[ __ ] shoot and all sorts of other
things and I think there you know you
got to stay smart and figure out what
business model works for you and the
rest of it what the right wait is this
isn't that they're doing something
across the board we know they're that
you're drinking the coffee in a gay way
no I'm drinking it you said business
model see that was that was a little bit
of that was I was only eating I can't
believe that you said that how would you
why would you why would you throw that
out it okay they don't know I've seen
you know most gay people use straws
continue because they're a tiny knuckle
I assume I don't know fatter do you ever
hear of a comedian known as Don Rickles
from the old days yes you know the Don
Rickles used to go up in front of a
crowd and he talked about the [ __ ]
over there and the black guy over there
the Jew over there and the wasp over
there the rest of it and guess what
everyone did everyone laughed and walked
out of there feeling equal yeah imagine
if you
like there was one group I just wasn't
gonna touch that that would actually
that would be twisted and that would be
bigotry right so these guys the bigger
issue of course is that we know they're
coming after you they're coming after me
the line just keeps moving and and I'm
not even gonna go into the amount of
crazy far-left YouTube channels out
there that say all sorts of evil stuff
and go on and on against Christians and
white men and all that all the terrible
stuff that they're doing all the time
right actually no those guys are gonna
be saved so yeah we gotta figure out how
to be smarter here well I appreciate and
I do appreciate the kind words and
support and you know what I would never
make a joke about you being lispy
because there's no truth to it you
actually speak more clearly
I wonder your you and Andrew Clavin you
have like a natural broadcaster voice
you talk here this day vroom
well actually here's one thing what do I
do whenever I do uh not impressions
whenever I record whatever no this is my
dave rubin is more like this it's very
sort of enunciated and when he talks
it's very almost labored and that he's
very thoughtful in his approach whenever
i talk about somebody or i'm saying that
somebody made a statement i invariably
do an impression i don't even mean to I
couldn't not do an impression like this
when talking about the Vox guy I
couldn't I've never done that I've done
an impression of you inadvertently when
I mentioned that yet Dave Rubin and I
were talking and I go into that it's
just a natural thing I've done since I
was a kid but but also we should note
that this guy his Twitter handle has the
word gay in it so he's putting it out
there as if it's part of something and
then it's like you can't you can't say
to you well you can't reference that
that very thing that you're making such
a part of your identity you know I mean
like it's such a small portion too
that's the thing I appreciate it because
I know a lot of concerns tried to you
know they got scared at first and then
now it's not just conservatives everyone
has jumped in every original content
creator because I know it's coming for
them but it really is one of those
scenarios where yelling listen it's
maybe 2% 2% of 2% of our content 2% of
our content is a Vox rebuttal and 2% of
that is making fun of the guy we
actually provide resources and
information we try to rebut it okay we
do have to get going so on Twitter is at
Rubin report as well as on YouTube and
Sydney Rubin thank you so much please go
back to the angry gay mafia and let them
know that just tell me you don't like me
on me
[Music]